grégoire ludig et david marsais du
palmashow avait été anoblie récemment
c'est ça une certaine manière j'ai
l'impression qu'on nous a demandé on a
gentiment été invités donc on va dire
oui avec plaisir vous remettez quel prix
ce soir un nouveau prix tout à fait en
remet les meilleurs effets visuels c'est
la première fois de l'histoire des
césars que ce prix est remis on est très
fiers de leurs maîtres nous on est très
très cas l'effet visuel
clairement bah oui un petit peu parce
qu'on se rappelle quand même de votre
prestation dans mandibules aux côtés
d'une mouche géante
j'ai un petit peu bosser ce qui m'amène
d'ailleurs à parler de votre partenaire
dans le monde i pul adèle exemple au
dénommé ce soir pour être nommé ce
savoyard garder avec elle on
évidemment comment est ce que vous avez
fait pendant ton âge pour garder votre
calme paris n'a pas gagné
de la table quand elle amène le plat moi
je regardais son épaule parce que je
suis regardé dans les yeux je n'arrivais
pas
vous avez prévu quoi sur scène quelque
chose de drôle
un homme canon par yahia pas génial ça
va être bien aux effets visuels il faut
rester sur canal+ les vedettes c'est
notre dernier film dénonce justement
cinéma qu'il faut absolument les porcs
parce que c'est juste génial c'est drôle
du début à la fin grégoire ludig chante
très très bien
qu'est-ce qui tirait simplement d'annecy
recevant un prix il remerciera tout le
monde y chanterait exactement m ar il
dirait généreux sur césar et vous verrez
vous comprendrez envoyé en ahl ans voilà
c'est mieux que cela comme ça peut-être
qu'il rencontre aux dépens du conte avec
ces trucs un peu
pas évident merci beaucoup merci à tous
les deux